when it comes on to crypto time what was
the number you said about percentage of
Republicans how they feel about crypto
yeah there is a in all the polling now
you have issues pulling at certainly
starting to starting to rain down on us
as we get closer and closer to the
debate stage and 46 of core Republicans
and they were looking at broad base so
not City Base but it was broad-based
sure
um did you know we're skeptical of
crypto and only when they give them a
five-point scale of what on whether you
feel positively about something very
positive positive neutral negative
negative so a standard Leica five point
scale only six percent of them said they
felt positive about crypto and they had
skepticism about it and saw a risk in it
so that's so that's that's an issue for
you because in the name of
Entrepreneurship you're also bringing
that sector I regard crypto as sort of a
sector of a larger entrepreneurial
ecosystem that's fair that comes with it
every sector has got its risk and this
happens to be tied to financial services
but you have a lot of Voters in there
they're like I'm not sure about this
which also can kind of attached to you a
little bit yeah look I think that's a
fair point
um for me the way I look at it is it's
an ecosystem play as you sort of stated
it right which is we are number one in
the nation and wage growth right we've
created a ton of high-paying jobs and
part of that is because we've leaned
into generational Technologies right we
haven't been afraid of those
generational Technologies like you said
there are risks involved I often cite
the example of Netscape and Napster
right everybody remembers Netscape and
Napster they're no longer with us right
their companies did not succeed but what
they created changed the world right
um you know you obviously have Spotify
Apple music Etc and then you have Google
um
Etc so
the initial Technologies don't often or
the initial companies don't often
succeed but the technology changes the
world I think with crypto part of the
problem is our elected officials don't
understand it many of them a b they
haven't and this is this is I think a
failure of the Biden Administration they
have not created rules
uh to allow people to play on an equal
footing and to be domestic companies as
opposed to Offshore companies right and
so we've seen what's happened the sort
of disaster there not having any rules
related to custody assets which is what
you know banking rules are right sort of
basic rules doesn't matter whether it's
a cryptocurrency or otherwise it's an
asset you've got to have rules on how
you custody that asset what you can do
with those customer assets
um you know no no rules as to whether
some things are regulated by uh by the
Commodities uh uh uh exchange or whether
they're regulated by the SEC right I
mean so so you have a lot of vagueness
in terms of the products that you create
what class does this live in exactly and
so you have not created an inviting uh
environment you're now starting to see
Republican Congress uh men Amer which is
the majority
um Whip and others uh be very Pro crypto
and even Democrats are becoming more
pro-crypto now because I think they
realize how many people are have crypto
accounts so I don't know how old that
particular poll is that you're talking
about it's it's coming right now it's
you were saying it's going to come out
now no it's it's it's coming in the last
three days as these issues can I ask you
a question I can't put you on the debate
stage yeah of course mayor Suarez of
course mayor Suarez you're paid in
crypto so obviously you have some
affinity and you've tried to attract it
to your city yeah what would you say the
American voter that is still skeptical
about it I would say that um you know
things like artificial intelligence
things like cryptocurrencies uh things
like Quantum Computing are going to
redefine the future if I can find a way
to prevent my child from being a lot of
time on this thing then maybe we can
have a different conversation but the
truth is that we can stick our head in
the sand and pretend like it doesn't
exist it's not going to benefit our
children and I'm running for president
because I want to create prosperity for
the maximum number of Americans and the
only way to do that is not to be afraid
of the future but to lean into the
future here's here's what by the great
answer here's what I would say to you I
think crypto Community is a political
party I don't know how big it is but it
is a political party and whoever wins it
sometimes
you know mayor Giuliani ran for
president 2004 what was the year when he
ran 04 or 2000 one of those years when
he ran and he was way ahead of his time
that some of the stuff that he said if
he would have ran 10 years later 16
years later you know he would have won
or you know a lot of people talked about
that but some of the stuff he talked
about wasn't yet bought was there one
prior to this by the way can you check
if there was a campaign prior to this so
for me crypto you're seeing what
happened with nfts there's a lot of
people that are just not fans of nfts
crypto Bitcoin ain't going away the
convention is here every year in Miami
it's craziness you go there all the time
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]